any attempt to control a student's
behavior is you guessed it white
supremacy things like making sure that
you're following directions and making
sure that you're sitting quietly and you
are in your seat and all these things
that come from
white culture so if we're positively
enforcing these behaviors we are by
extension positively enforcing elements
of white culture which therefore keeps
whiteness at the center which is the
definition of white supremacy what a
smarmy little squirrel this guy is this
is not only incredibly demeaning but
it's also plainly false you'll notice
how the crt cult makes sweeping
assertions about the nature of whiteness
and and the things that derive from
whiteness but they never make any
attempt to prove any of these assertions
this is what makes it fun and easy to be
a member of the cult it's perhaps the
primary attraction it almost makes me
want to join the cult sometimes
sometimes i want to to be a member of
the crt cult for this reason because it
just has it must be so great to be able
to make any wild claim you want and
never be asked to justify it or provide
any evidence whatsoever